at that point in time my main mission
get it back to australia
we bought a whole heap of crystal meth
from zack suppliers
big snaplock bags of drugs so
we bought a whole heap of gift sets that
had bath salts in them
there was a process
we would have to make sure that we had
gloves on
hair nets
so we'd lay that plastic
because we didn't want any kind of
evidence left no fingerprints no dna
and we were naked
it's like open-heart surgery
take the soap out
separate it all
with screw jars they have like the
plastic around the side
i would cut that plastic
empty the contents like into a bowl
weigh it making sure that match the
weight of it on the jar
i don't want any residue on the outside
of the jar
i would get a very fine low torch
and i'd seal it
put all the stuff back into the box
it looks as about as not tampered with
as i could possibly make it
[Music]
once the product was perfect it got
shipped with other items that had to go
out so it all looked part of the same
parcel with my company name on the back
so yeah
[Music]
these packages would get tracked
once we knew it got there a few days
later we were heaps excited about it
then the money would be wired
the job is done we started sending
packages on a regular basis it worked
out to be about 320 000
a month
it wasn't going to be forever
and then i could legitimize myself and
focus on my modelling
[Music]
i'd be in front of the camera boom in my
mind i'm like oh got to get a gift set
today that had bath salts in them and
that's what i'm thinking is i'm getting
told to pull my midsection in
i lived a double life
by day
i'm a swimsuit model gracing the pages
of magazines nighttime
i'm packaging drugs to send
overseas
those two worlds for me were very real
and
i couldn't have him collide
[Music]
i now had so much money it's obscene
i could just walk into anywhere purchase
whatever i wanted at whatever time
and not even blink an eyelid
i walked around thinking i was the best
thing since sliced bread
what are you doing today we're gonna go
and watch a show in broadway in new york
i'm gonna book a flight now
can't get a flight let's get a g6
it's
yeah
i wish in my mind now that i looked at
those times and thought that could send
me to jail for the rest of my life but i
didn't know any different
[Music]
when you have financial freedom like
that
if you have no discipline you run a muck
and that's pretty much what happened
i wasn't turning up for shoots
drugs were rife
it wasn't the cause of my demise but we
got out of control
i thought the power the success and the
money and i would be happy for once in
my life and i wasn't
i was not fulfilled i had not found love
i was so hollow and empty
why can't i just go into the supermarket
and let it be like a can
of like love
a can of family and i'll buy all that
and i'll be right because i knew what
was
missing you know
[Music]
you